on n'imaginait pas qu'on puisse tuer des
hommes comme ça et je parle pas les
femmes et des enfants robert hébras
cette aide à oradour sur glane le 10
juin 1944 ce jour-là une division ss
investi le village hier un village
aujourd'hui et pour toujours un des
hauts lieux de la cruauté hitlériennes
je vais voir ma petite soeur et qui s à
l'école qui pleure parce qu'elle a peur
et je vais l'avoir désarmé t'inquiète
pas on va rentrer à la maison
c'est par ce vote afin de marc je lui
disais ça
sincèrement à deux heures de
l'après-midi les ss sont venus
ils ont rassemblé toute la population
sur cette place
les femmes et les enfants on les a
rassemblés dans l'église et on les ya
mitrailler et brûlé vif les hommes
on les emmenait dans les granges et
abattus ont baissé la fusillade qui me
trouvent sur les autres
on vous rassure les morts
c'est quand même
un moment difficile
643 personnes sont massacrés par les
nazis six personnes survivent dont
robert hebras je veux se cacher la junte
a black hoof ont entendu parler français
j'ai vu que c'était déjà où je
connaissais ça a été un soulagement pour
moi robert hebras a attendu le début des
années 70 pour témoigner à la télé le 10
juin 1944 vous étiez dans cette grange
oui mais chez était là cette grange
comment vous avez de vous échapper
c'est la destinée qui me fait échapper
c'est tout aujourd'hui je me rends
compte que c'est un pont tard mais à
l'époque je les fais parce que
je me suis toujours
rapproché des enfants de la commune sa
mort est plus près des jeunes de
l'extérieur je les recevais dans les
rues et de leur expliquer ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui robert hebras à 96 ans
il est le dernier témoin vivant de ce 10
juin 1944
aujourd'hui il y en a un message c'est
que on revit un
débat sacre en revue des massacres moi
ça me touche beaucoup
malheureusement j'ai peur que
nos petits enfants et petits enfants et
des soucis avec
des poches arrière parce que trop bien
[Musique]